are you ready for more uncharted
goodness you might get even more of it
than you were expecting I'm Tony and
this is your bonus length gamespot news
update uncharted standalone DLC chapter
The Lost Legacy could be over 10 hours
long now I don't think anyone's out
there actually complaining about more
uncharted but just in case naughty dog's
head of communications aren't mayor
elaborated on this with IBTimes UK he
said there's no way we could constrict
and restrain ourselves and that's
exactly what was happening here when we
were doing our story pitches we were
coming up with a game that would be over
10 hours long and so we suddenly
realized everything we said was true
then we couldn't keep it short The Lost
Legacy is coming to ps4 at some point
this year and then that'll be the end of
the uncharted saga for the foreseeable
future plenty of other 2017 games have
story DLC on the way too including
horizon zero dawn and Zelda for more of
that you can check out six more amazing
things we wish we knew about breadth of
the wild
[Music]